hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast the stabilization and
degradation of myc
more ways than one presented by dr.
Jason de Melo postdoctoral fellow at
Princess Margaret Cancer Research at the
University of Health Network
I'm dr. Susie Valdez of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roost lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on that screen and our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers educational credits please follow
the continuing education credits tab
located on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter dr. Jason de Mello I will now
turn the presentation over to him
welcome sir
Thank You Susie and thank you for
everyone allah Brutes and the organizers
of the cancer research and oncology
event for providing me with this
presentation opportunity I was a little
between the title I'll be discussing
some of our work within the Penn lab
studying the regulation of the Mik
protein as therapeutic implications
within cancer before I get sorry I just
wanted to kind of highlight what I want
everyone to get out of this presentation
today first off I want I would like the
attendees to get a an idea about the
gain an appreciation for the critical
role play Mick plays within tumor
Genesis
also to develop an understanding of how
the amount of Mik croaking within a cell
helps dictate the fate of the cell and
also understand how true how little we
truly know about this how the stability
of the make protein is regulated and why
this is hindered our ability to develop
a therapeutic strategy against neck so
to start off what is mech the Mik
protein which is also known as semen is
a member of the mixed family of
transcription factors the other family
members are n maconel MEK Olmec family
mem members act as transcription factors
that bind to DNA conserved regions term
D boxes these boxes tend to be within
promoter regions of DNA promoter regions
and enhancer regions of DNA
however non-canonical make binding sites
when genome have also been identified
and Mick Elma can see make sure much
secret homology but they differ in their
expression profiles and maconel make are
primarily expressed during development
and were identified in neuroblastoma and
lung cancer respectively seem ik however
has expressed throughout development and
in adult tissues and it's increased
expression is associated with many
cancers so what role does Mick play
within normal cells and why is it so
important many of the genes regulated
regulated from make are important for
cell growth metabolism deliberation all
of which are important for growing cell
unsurprisingly the amount of making the
cells correlated with the village divide
as the amount of Mick increases it
reaches a critical threshold whereas the
cell is able to enter a proliferative
state at the proliferative state the
cell is able to divide however there's
also a second threshold which is an
eighth pop tonic threshold if the amount
of making a cell reaches this point
instead of divided this is potentially
oncogenic and instead of normally
dividing the cell will end up going
through apoptosis and die however during
tumor Genesis and cancer development
secondary mutations within a pop tonic
machinery such as DNA damage response
that prevent the cell from undergoing
apoptosis are gained and this allow the
cells to maintain Mik at
genik levels this allows a cell to
divide and proliferate uncontrollably
but normal cells in the expression make
is tightly controlled and so what we
want to know is how do cancer cells
increase the amount of Mik levels that
allow them to proliferate uncontrollably
we know that Mick is a key driver of
chima Genesis many cells acquire
amplifications of the McVean roughly 20%
of all cancers have amplifications or
increased numbers of copies of the Mik
gene beyond the typical to use it we'll
see it with a normal cell however
despite its importance within tumor
Genesis Mik is surprisingly under
mutated there's only one known mutation
within Mik
that's acts as a driver for cancer
however while 2030 percent of cancers
have genetic lesions within the Macondo
gene 50 to 70 percent of cancers have
dysregulation to make protein and
increased expression of the Mik protein
underlying alternative mechanisms to
increase make to allow a cell to divide
uncontrollably so how do how what other
pathways are able to increase the amount
of Mik wouldn't sell there primarily
three main witness one is through
mutations of other alpha genes such as
PHP kinase went or or - that can all
lead to a variant signaling which
increases the expression and regulation
of the mick protein that were mentioned
in genetic lesions such as
amplifications or translocations of the
mix into a different promoter all
increase expression in the Mik gene
while the one characterized mutation
mutation of t58 prevents the efficient
degradation in the make protein and
finally ultra stability of the mRNA
protein or pro translational
modifications of a protein can all
conspire to alter Mik levels in many
cases in multiple oncogenic events can
converge to increase the amount of make
in the cell such as amplifications of
the machines as well as mutations of
upstream signaling processes such as pi3
kinase pathway mutations the net effect
is increased levels of Meg protein and
increased activity
as a transcription that increased
activity as a transcription factor so
how does Mik function as a transcription
factor Mik binds to its binding partner
max forms a heterodimer and then
searches DNA for Mik binding sites and
eat boxes once it finds these binding
sites it's able to recruit molecules to
these regions of DNA is too altered in
the genomic landscape or increased
expression
this can include histone
acetyltransferases such as that's a gcn5
stag tip 60 that acidity histones open
up chromatin and allow polymerase RNA
polymerase 2 to come in and transcribe
genes
alternatively Mik can recruit
transcription factors and elongation
factors such as PTFE to modify RNA pol
directly and allow transcription to
occur
finally McCann repressive elements such
as g9 ALP or mids one that methyl II
histones and contract DNA to prevent RNA
pol tube from accent accessing genes and
allowing for active transcription all
these functions lead to a model were
McCormack as a general amplify routine
transcription Mick is able to open up
and control the genomic and landscape
and recruit RNA polymerase to allow more
gene transcription to occur essentially
as a amount of mechana cell increases
more Mick is bound to chromatin and
allowing more modifications and more
transcription to occur so how is this so
important well Mick bites at ten to
fifteen percent of the genome may make
it's a very promiscuous transcription
factor and able to to change the a very
large transcriptional program this
transcriptional program is involved in
the growth metabolism proliferation
apoptosis stemness and migration of the
cell and all these are important factors
for tumor Genesis this also means that
targeting make would would be a great
therapeutic strategy
if we can decrease the amount of Mik in
the cell decrease the make levels we
could potentially cut the cell into self
stasis State or where the cell would no
longer grow and this would potentially
impact the 50 to 70 percent of patients
have increased expression of the make of
the main protein the problem arises in
trying to develop a drug against Mik Mik
is on an enzyme and as a transcription
factor it's intrinsically disordered
most small molecule inhibitors are
designed against enzymes and structured
regions of proteins making make a poor
target and when is often referred to as
I'm druggable alternatively we can try
and target the mechanism which
mechanisms which conspire to increase
the amount of Mikan cell
however we know surprisingly little
about how the Mik protein is regulated
my work focuses on trying to
characterize how the stability of the
make protein is regulated by post
translational modifications also known
as PTMs the MEK protein is actually been
shown to be heavily modified by post
translational modifications to date
about 70 modifications have been in debt
by through high put three two point
means such as mass spec or low
throughput techniques such as mutational
analysis here we can see a schematic as
reported on the web tool fossil site
this is in line with the consensus that
make the mick protein is tightly
regulated within the cell however the
only PT in that I mean characterized our
theory nearly 58 in series 62 as I
mentioned there any 50 AIDS mutations
were identified a Burkitt's lymphoma and
represent the only known cancer causing
mutation in the main protein the
regulatory mechanism centered around T
58 and s 62 forms the only characterized
degradation pathway only known
characterized degradation pathway from X
in this pathway Mick becomes
phosphorylated sequentially as a serine
62 in 3958 by mitogen stimulated kinase
such as irk and GSK to be baited
respectively this puts make into an
active state allowing it to allowing
tracks
in joker pin1 and protein phosphatase to
a are able to then come in and work
together to d phosphorylates the serine
62 leaving mick and with a sole
phosphorylation at their in a 58 this
forms a recognition sequence for an HP
ligase sdff BW 7 which is able to
interact with the theory 950
phosphorylated mick you pick related
leading to a stag relation at the
produce all while other III like users
have been reported from ik this is the
only known regulatory pathway to date so
why is mutation of TPP HMO genic and
sorry and you the de aquila is USB 28
works to counteract the subiculum and
keep mix prevent me from being degraded
so why is the mutation of t 58 so
tumorigenic the half-life of the Mik
protein is about 30 minutes that is it
takes 30 minutes for 50% of the Mik
protein to be degraded under normal
conditions mutation at T 58 to alanine
doubles the half-life to approximately
60 minutes this corresponds to an
increase in mass increased amount of
making the cells and increased image
intensity essentially you've doubled the
amount of Mick within the cell putting a
button bluntly more MEK equals more
tumor growth and we see that when we
look at assays of tumor Genessa T in
which Anessa T mutation of T 58
increases the amount of us in this case
colony we see on South Bay grasses which
is an surrogate marker for tumor growth
however as I mentioned Mick has a
half-life of 30 minutes making it a very
liable protein that gets degraded very
quickly the median half-life of all
proteins within the cell is about 46
hours if the GSK 3 beta and xdx a
pathway was the only degradation pathway
from it would expect a greater increase
in the half-life and make protein when
we inhibit this pathway so what else is
degrading Mick when sdff bw7 isn't this
form is one of the main research themes
for the pen lab try and understand how
the Mick protein is regulated in the
and conversely how it is deregulated in
cancer my research project centers on
this hypothesis on the hypothesis and
Mik protein is heavily modified by post
translational modifications as I
mentioned about over 70 many of these
PTM may form part of another regulatory
pathway for me that we can exploit to
develop a therapeutic strategy to treat
patients with increased expression of
mech in their cancers begin to address
this we first decided to focus on
clusters of residues which have been
shown to be modified by post
translational modifications in the
n-terminal transactivation domain of MEK
centered around nick botswana mix box -
there are six lysine residues by row
which has been shown to be modified by
post translational modifications we
decided to mutate all of these arginine
and see what effect this would have on
the mixed protein in a soft a piace
where the over expression of mech allows
colonies to grow under Anchorage
independent conditions which is
indicative of a cell growing in the
tumor environment we see that Mick is
able to drive in tumor growth or tumour
cell growth in these Tet 21
neuroblastoma cells under these
conditions mutating these six unlike
seen residues to arginine dramatically
decreases the amount and size of the
colonies we see because these residues
are spread over a wide region of Mik we
decided to separate these into two
smaller clusters the lysines around Mik
box one term which we termed 2k RN and
lysine residues around Mik box 2 which
we term for Karen these residues are
these residues seem as a logical place
to split this this larger cluster what
happen we see is that the 4k mutation of
the for k4 lysine residues around Mik
box 2 has minimal effect on the ability
of mikta mikta drive tumor cell growth
whereas mutineer the two lysine residues
in Mik box 1 you know copies what we see
with 6 care and and dramatically
decreases the amount of tumor growth
see these two lysine residues in Mik box
one lysine 51 and 52 are side by side
our initial hypothesis hypothesis was
that these two like scenes would be
redundant that mutating one what either
one would have no effect however this
was in the case when you take lysine 51
we see very minimal effect on the
ability of mixer drive trimmer Genesis
however where mutate lysine 52 we see
the dramatic decrease in tumor cell
growth these conditions and the which
phenol copies what we saw was 6 care and
and two care this implicated lexing 52
was a causative as an important residue
from Mik function and the causative
residue or mutation for that 6 care and
phenotype that we were seeing we decided
to take this into xenograft assay in
this assay we injected we transducer out
1a cells with Mick Mick or our mutants
of interest when these cells are grown
subcutaneously to not skid mice the
cells that Express overexpressing
are able to develop very large tumors
very quickly in contrast to the cells
which did not carry any mate or the
empty vector cells the lesion of Mick
box 2 which is a known loss of function
mutation for Mick is able is unable to
drive this tumor growth phenotype that
we see with Mick when we look our to
care and kaif if you want to keep
through two mutants of interest we see
that two karin caifa be to form very
small tumors where Scafe everyone grows
a large tumor very much like make
wild-type Mick this again adds further
evidence to implicate that k52 is the
causative mutation leading to this loss
function phenotype and it might be
important for Mick function these
mutations are mutant license our genes
while this is a relatively conservative
a have a structural change under the NIC
protein again the Mick protein is
structural intrinsically disordered has
very little secondary structure however
we wanted to make sure that what we were
seeing was due to a functional change in
our structure
all change our collaboration Sweden dr.
Maria suna Hagen and Vivian Moran used
used circular dichroism spectroscopy to
assess the secondary structure the Mac
Pro team this technique uses circular
polarized life to assess the absorption
of the protein over a range of
wavelengths allowing us assess changes
in secondary structure specifically beta
sheets and alpha helix ease what we
observed was that there was no
difference in the secondary structure
after mutating like scene 51 52 or both
of them together indicating that the
changes we were seeing was due to a
functional console is a functional
consequence of the mutation and not a
structural consequence so why is 1550 do
so important it resides in a highly
conserved region of Meg termed Mick Box
116 52 in future and the shirani
residues are a 100% conserved across all
myth or go myth orthologs our main
orthologs including n mech Helmick and
myth or orthologs for species as their
version as chimps rabbits cats fish and
frogs indicating that there's an
evolutionary reason for keeping these
lysine residues around moreover when we
look at fossils i+ we can either Lexi
fifty-two has been shown to be modified
by some ETS specifically these PGM the
period
Lexi 52 seems to be modified by ubique
relation and simulation however the
consequence of these modifications are
still really under investigation it is
very unclear at this point when we were
doing our experiments we noticed that
the expression of two kr and K 51 in
case of QED it's particularly to carry
any key future which is much lower than
our wild-type Mik or the make mutants we
didn't know if this was due to an
expression issue or this was due to the
functional consequence in the protein
when we looked at the mRNA expression we
saw no change in the mRNA expression of
these proteins what typically happens
what typically happens during a protein
life cycle is that it becomes Express
MRNA is this convergent at protein at
the ribosome and eventually it gets poly
regulated by me feel a gaze leading to
its degradation if and Lexi residues are
known to be modified by ubiquitin
leading to a potential degradation
phenotype we wanted to see if this was
due to protozoal degradation we treated
the cells with mg 1/3 to 1/4 of the
proteasome we're able to prevent produce
OMA Democratic relation and look at
accumulation of the Mik protein if the
decreased ability of lysine 52 was due
to increase pretty little more
degradation this should rescue the love
of protein levels and this is indeed
what we see treating with mg 1 3 2
rescues the amount of rescues the
stability phenotype or the protein
levels of the to care and in k-50 within
the cell indicating that lighting 52 or
me to eating this to an arginine renders
or increases the amount of proteomic
relation we observe to look at this in
another way we want to see the stability
of the Mik protein after mutation of
lysine 52 we treat the cells of
cycloheximide an inhibitor of protein
translation by targeting the ribosome we
prevent the conversion of mRNA and
jeopardy
we were then able to monitor how long it
takes for the Mik protein the remaining
make protein within the cell to be
degraded at the proteasome what we see
is that after treating the cells with
Cyclops mi40 15 30 45 60 or 90 minutes
you can see that the half-life of the
Mik protein is about 30 minutes meaning
that it takes about 30 minutes for 50%
of the protein to be degraded when we
look at the 2 K or a mutant
see that the half-life drops to about 21
minutes mutating K 51 our alone has
minimal change on the half-life to make
protein has about 27 minute half life
whereas lysine mutating lysine 52 to
arginine again replicates what we see
with to Karin and had
like about 21 minutes this indicates and
it adds further evidence to the idea
that mutating like secret to destabilize
to make protein by causing increased
protozoan degradation as you mention the
most well Christ's degradation pathway
from it is through SCF FBX w7 Lexington
t2 is very near there 1858 and s62
within mick box 1 there was a potential
that by mutating this lysine residue we
were having an effect on the canonical
degradation pathway permit so we'd use
two independent approaches to assesses
we first looked at phosphorylation asan
no change in phosphorylation then we use
CRISPR caste 9 genome editing to knock
out SDF bw7
in our wild-type cells as we saw with
the previous slide the half-life of mech
is about 30 minutes and the caterer
half-life is about 15 minutes or about
sorry 18 minutes when we you when we
knock out as FBX that FBX w7 using
CRISPR cast 9 we decrease or we increase
the half of the mixture approximately 63
minutes and the KFOR sure increases
about 34 minutes respectively but
tellingly we should see a dramatic
difference in the amount and the
stability of 1652 mutants
if this was due to the FBX fbw 7 we
would expect the half-life 2 are to be
rescued and to be around 60 minutes
seeing that we still see a differential
in these cells it would indicate that
the degradation pathway is independent
of FB w7 it still exists even when we
knock out every w7 that's an independent
approach we took advantage of the net
elation inhibitor mln 494 Cullen dream
ligases such as SCF PDX w7 rely on
methylation of the Cullen backbone in
order to mate remain active and able to
poly Berkeley and degraded substrates
when we treat with mln 492 for this
inhibits activation of ned 8 and prevent
stimulation of the colon backbone we use
this to
as an independent way to assess if FPS
w7 was important for degradation of the
lysine 52 mutant when we treated cells
with Emeline for nine to four we see
that the methylated Cullen one
disappears after treatment we also see
increases in the other known target of
SCIF bw7 cyclin e when you look
specifically what's happening with Meg
we see that after treatment with Mick or
with the mln for nine to four we see an
increase in the amount of Mick protein
roughly a doubling we look at the T 58 a
mutant we don't see any change or any
noticeable change in the amount of
protein in the cell as this is already
protected within this pathway by
mutation mutating this key their unique
residue we look at to Karen we see an
increase but tellingly it doesn't reach
the same levels as Mick or T 50 day it's
not rescued keep one hour reaches those
levels we see with Mick and T 50 a day
in k52 our does not this is in contrast
at what we saw with mg 1 to B 2 we
inhibit all presume a dimer depredation
were able to completely rescue the
levels Mick in these cells whereas if we
cheat with ml n 494 which only inhibits
colon ring ligases such as SCF FBX w7 we
don't see that effect we don't see that
complete rescue
this leads does putting together a
working model in this model we suspect
that Mick is unstable when has no post
translational modifications in this and
in our model lysine modifying enzyme
will come in and add a post
translational modification and she Baker
relation simulation set elation to
lysine 52 leading to recruitment
allowing stabilization and act and
maintaining making an inactive state
allowing it to interact with other
protein protein interactors however if
no ppm is added to a single key to make
make is unstable leading to its poly
regulation and degradation
bye-bye and III ligase in this model the
lysine modifying enzyme which adds the
post entries like post translational
modification onto lysine 52 would be a
very promising therapeutic target to
develop a strategy of target making
cancer our goal is now to identify the
e3 ligase the Lexy modifying enzyme and
it's entering the interacting partners
that keep making an active state to
identify therapeutic strategies and put
together this entire degradation and
regulatory mechanism to do this we're
taking advantage of by ID by OID is a
technique where a board of biotin ligase
is fused to your protein of interest in
our case make this fight in ligase
when it's able to activate biotin but
releases it in proximity of your protein
interest and actually tag any proximal
proteins or protein protein
Interactive's
so we express leave themselves the Mik
protein will interact with interacting
partners when exogenous biotin is added
this will be tagged the protein-protein
interaction partners which we can then
harvest and purify using streptavidin
beads and send from mass spec analysis
identifying those protein interactors
our lab is previously used this to
identify the Mik interactome
and fully characterize new interaction
partners forming my approach has been to
now take this a step further in addition
to doing the wild-type interactome look
at the Mik interaction for the to care
and K 51 R and K 52 mutants k52 are
mutants
identify their individual interactions
and compare them to one another to see
what changes occur in order to identify
any potential therapeutic
memories of this degradation pathway in
therapeutic targets this strategy is
based on some of the information that
and the data we've developed we know
that to Karen and Keith if you are both
have a shorter half-life and reduce
ability to transform cells likely
meaning that they are acting in a very
similar way mutation of lysine 51 has
normal half-life and transformation
potential seems to be unaffected
therefore if we look at the individual
interact owns and we focus on those
changes and then interact them that are
unique to to care and in case if you are
but our independent of changes in K 51
our interact them we may be able to
identify these different different
members of this degradation pathway we
recently done this work we we've
collected the interactions of each of
these proteins and done this analysis we
have actually identified any three
ligase that we suspect is increased in
our lexing 52 are mutated samples that
we're trying to assess more fully we
found the lysine modifying enzyme which
decrease in our mutant which we suspect
it's because it's no longer able to
interact with us and modify the Mik
protein that might be important for this
pathway we've also identified changes in
protein complexes that interact with
making are important for make function
right now our work is characterizing
these different approaches to help
identify this regulatory pathway and
hopefully develop a strong therapeutic
strategy we can potentially move it to
the clinic so in summary there are
learning objectives my learning
objectives for this course or for this
session was to learn about the critical
role it plays in tumor Genesis we know
that make binds at 10 to 15 percent of
the genome as an important
transcriptional program that helps
mediate tumor Genesis primarily by by
pushing the cell 2 into a growth and
proliferate a phase
I wanted to get across the understanding
that the relationship between the amount
of making the protein and cell has a
direct impact on it's too much in a city
as the MEK reaches the critical point
the lumic levels within the cell this
cell can enter a proliferative stage
however too much to make results in an
oncogenic state which in normal
conditions would trigger the cell to
undergo apoptosis and die our cancer
cells which require mutations in these a
pop sonic pathways are able to tolerate
high levels of making able to
proliferate uncontrollably
I wanted to understand how little we
actually know about how the make protein
is regulated health stability is
regulating the cell and how this is
hindered our ability to develop strong
therapeutic strategies against Mick we
know about the GS KS f bw7
degradation pathway but now we have a
potential new pathway which we can
develop more therapies so I'd like to
thank everyone all members of the Penn
lab my supervisor Linda Penn and our
collaborators to brine route and dr.
Maria Stern or Hagen and what questions
do you have
thank you dr. down below for that
informative presentation and we will now
start that Q&A portion of the webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type the question into the box that
appear on the screen and click that send
button our speaker will follow up with
you via email so here are some questions
from our viewers right now dr. de novo
mutation of licen residues is typically
associated with the stabilization of a
protein by preventing Paul you you pick
up a hard time with that word poly
ubiquitin and degradation
why does mutation of k52 destabilize myc
that's a great question so what we it's
true that typically when you mutate
lysine residues you see a stabilization
by preventing Paul UVic relation however
what we see with two is sobs that we see
a D state later
with poly relation the degradation
mechanism is typically served with
lysine 48 and now lysine 11 linked deep
in Chains
this is triggers this is recognized by
the chromosome and triggers degradation
but however the other lysine
modifications that can occur such as
lysine
in Chains simulation asset elation are
not necessarily associated with
degradation this is why we suspect that
the modification that's occurring on
that license of you is actually not a
lysine 48 the bickerin chain or lysine
11 you pick one chain one of these other
less known or less characterized lycée
modifications thank you for that answer
and are there any other III like Isis
reported for the myc protein yeah there
have been a number of studies reporting
like that are able to degrade Mickey to
be like aces these include beta T CRP
skip to QE 1 e ll to name a few these
have been mostly one-off studies that
have identified in et lag is as
important for degrading mink but not
necessarily one that are degradation
pathway that we can exploit and also
it's important to note that targeting an
e to be ligase would not be a viable
therapy approach we won't make G be
degraded that we actually want that each
e leg is to be active so we need to find
as the other components decoration
pathway that are important for his
degradation and the what's interesting
to notice that in our data where I
showed treatment with the mln 492 for
which is that inhibitor of all Cullen
being like aces a beta CCR piece if q is
your other coloring like ages that are
also inhibited in those settings so that
data also implicates non coloring ligase
in this degradation pathway so it's also
gives us further evidence thank you and
a final question for you dr. Mello why
haven't any therapeutics against my
sieve been developed we've known about
Mick for about 30 years it's been a very
challenging protein to work with
historically it's buried within the
chromatin that's been it's it's libel
libel it degrades very quickly has no
very structure and our best therapeutics
in small medical today have been all
designed against enzymes that have very
defined and somatic Park it's very easy
to target so Mick has been one of those
those proteins
been considered undruggable to date
there has been a lot more recent success
using inhibitors such as JQ one in the B
or D for inhibitors that don't at Target
to be ready for when don't directly
target Mik but have a dramatic impact on
the expression of ink so again by
decreasing the amount of making a cell
there seems to be it seems to be a
therapeutic vulnerability we can take
advantage of cap cancer so as we're
starting to learn more about how Mick is
regulated and how Mick is expressing the
cells and how different ways that we can
decrease the amount of making the cells
we have a much better chance now
developing these therapies dr. de Mello
thank you for your presentation today
and thank you for your important
research I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
January 2019 they'll receive an email
from lab roots letting you know that
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with you our colleagues who may have
missed today's event that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we hope to
see you again soon bye-bye